there are 43 quintillion possible
combinations
now imagine you have no websites no
books and no one to show you how to
solve it because you invented it
[Music]
but you didn't invent the rubik's cube
this guy did my name is anne rubick i
was born here in this
beautiful city of budapest it was 1974.
thirty-year-old erno rubik was just
beginning his career in academia i was
lecturing design and architecture
it was very similar in age with the
students i was very ambitious to find
new ways to teach them especially about
space and three dimension i made a cube
as a teaching gate
and for myself to learn something from
it
once the physical cube was put together
erno began hunting for its secrets the
question was not
it is possible to solve it but the
question was it is possible to find a
method to do that there is 26
small cubes it looks the same but in the
structure of the cube they have
different rules erno racked his brain
for a strategy twisting and turning the
cube in his hands and his head to unlock
his creation after i started to
understand the nature of the structure
the movement
i found a way for a solution it's not a
straight way
and after a month he cracked the code
but the story doesn't end there
i had the feeling the potential of the
object i find it very simple to
manufacture and the result of that it
can be an object what is available for
everyone
in 1980 erno would finally bring his
cube to the world and from there it took
off becoming one of the best selling
toys of all time
because of the content of the cube the
world discovered is not a gadget it's
something that is more valuable more
long life and after almost 40 years
rubik's cube has seen a comeback with
hundreds of competitions every year
across the world
for erno the cube that bears his name is
more than just a toy
it's a reminder to never give up there
is always way for a solution that's
always a way to find something else
something new something different or
find a result of your work
if today is not
everything is good it suddenly tomorrow
can not be better
depend on you
[Music]
you